so what we're gonna talk about today and
I'm gonna do something a little annoying
as usual I want to take you somewhere
here yes you're back to carbon that's
fine but what I want to show you is the
sizes of the molecular players in
translation because we're going here now
from the smallest carbon atom and we
spent the first four lectures on amino
acids and nucleotides sugars
phospholipids but we're entering new
territory here
and I'm just going to do this in such a
way that it comes on to the sconce or
the screens
what you can see here is in order to
make proteins like hemoglobin and
antibodies these are made up of amino
acids the really tinier things that are
out of view right now we need large
entities that are made up of either
nucleic acids alone or nucleic acids
plus proteins and so the things that
we'll feature today and the transfer
RNAs and the ribosome and I want you to
look at the size of this molecular
machine this is we're getting pretty
large now we're needing to use large
machines to make the smaller catalysts
that are essential in the cell and just
so you sort of maybe size doesn't seem
so important but let's just go a little
bit further here and what to me is
intriguing is that the size of the
ribosome is pretty similar to the size
of the brain of iris a little smaller
than the hepatitis virus but quite a bit
smaller than some of these other viruses
so the ribosome organelle is a large
entity in the cell and when you do do
look at electron micrographs of cells
you can see these dark dots which
represent ribosomes they're big enough
to see whereas the proteins themselves
are not big enough to see so that's what
you're you're destined for today all
right
okay so I've started to place on this
board some of the molecular players the
messenger RNA the transfer RNA and the
ribosomes which are made up of ribosomal
RNA plus protein and I want to just
remind you about the structure of the
mature messenger RNA just for a minute
because in the last class we talked
about a lot of manipulations of that
message that pre messenger RNA the fresh
thing out of transcription and now I
just want to remind you that the
messenger is single-stranded RNA
obviously it has a five prime cap which
has got this moons funky 5 prime 5 prime
bridge that's resistant to exonucleases
somewhere in that sequence is a start
codon it's something that says this is
the bit I want to translate you often
there's a lot of stuff here that you
don't translate it's part of what's
known as the ribosome binding site and
there are many features in this part of
the sequence that a very important for
translation they contribute to the
efficiency of translation generically
we'd call it the ribosome binding site
but they're funny things called
shine-dalgarno sequences and stuff don't
worry about any of that I just want you
to appreciate that the mature transcript
you don't translate the whole thing a
lot of this stuff is structural
functional for other reasons that
contribute to the success of translation
once you see one of these the ribosome
owes its way through and reads the
nucleic acids in the message so the
message is being conveyed over to the
new machinery and then when you hit one
of these three codons and we'll discuss
these properly when we get to them it's
time to stop and finish translating the
other end of the message has a poly
adenine tail remember that once again is
structural to protect the ends
that transcript even if some of the
hundreds of adenine nucleotides I'd
nibbled off you don't get into the part
of the gene that's critical to be
translated at a certain stage though you
might get in exonucleases might chew up
enough and they may end up chewing up
your transcript but that probably
suggests that the messenger has been
around too long and it's time for it to
retire to a better life okay so remember
the poly a tail and this once again
plays other functional roles with
respect to being recognized as a
transcript and being helped to get out
of the nucleus so this was really what
we talked about last week there's one
more feature in here I'm just going to
remind you that the final mature
transcript has also been through
splicing with removal of introns and the
pasting together of exons which is a
wonderful way to diversify transcripts
of translation and give you much more
proteins than one gene can encode okay
and we talked about that last time great
so the first thing we have to think
about here is how do we go from core
bases to a language that includes 20
letters right oh yeah it's better really
more precise for me to call them
nucleotides it's more precise because
the base just represents the the ring
system that's attached to the ribose
nucleotide means the whole thing
including a phosphate so we go from four
bases to including 20 amino acids now
there are a few organisms and in fact we
have one spare one as well Celino
cysteine there are a couple of other
amino acids that might be designated as
the so-called 21st 22nd amino acid
they're not found globally in all
organisms we have Celino cysteine in
just very very few proteins
so it's something beyond the list of 20
that you saw there are other organisms
for example in our care these guys who
hang out in bubbling hot pots in
Yellowstone for example that have
another amino acid known as pure lysine
I'm gonna mention that a little bit
later on but the ones you really need to
think about are the ones we're encoding
in the global genetic code this is the
ones that are common to everybody
alright so obviously when you look at
the language of bases one base if the
language translated directly one base
it's one amino acid we could only encode
four amino acids so we know it's not one
base one amino acid and I know at this
stage you know that it's three bases but
let's just go through the math or the
original questions that were sort of
circulating like how do we go from this
language to the other language if two
bases encoded each amino acid we could
only encode eight amino acids that's not
enough still 16 I mean oh wait a minute
16 amino acids sorry
I can never anyway that's four to the
two it's pretty good if I can't get sort
of the two up at the blackboard this
would be 4 to the 1 power and then so
what that came down to realizing there
were not enough
that wouldn't be a sufficient language
to encode the 20 amino acids so it's
finally deduced that 3 bases encoded
each amino acid that would give us 64
possible words in the in the language
for the that needs to be translated
that's a lot more than we need we only
need 24 the encoded amino acids so 64
possibilities
but what else do we need in the language
we need a few more things anyway yeah
how there oh you bet so exactly so here
this is am unnecessarily one of the ones
that uniformly codes amino acids through
the sequence we need a precise way to
say start and in fact we need a way to
stay safe stop and there are multiple
three-letter words that say stop so it
turns out that the genetic code which
forms the basis of this entire concept
has some features to it where it does
have some degeneracy but we'll go
through the degeneracy and we'll take a
look at the genetic code because it will
tell us exactly how the three-letter the
the words made of three bases encode
everything we need for translation all
right so let's just go back and take a
look at this so we've looked at the
messenger
I've told you a little bit about the
tRNAs and the proteins but then we just
sort of give you a little bit of the
back history once the structure of
double-stranded DNA was deduced really
everyone was moving on to trying to
understand how that converted to the
translation to proteins and there were a
lot of workers deeply involved in this
Creek and Brenner realized it was three
bases to code for one a one amino acid
butcan karana nirenberg and Holly Kurama
who was part of our faculty for many
many years actually defined that genetic
code and got all of the details
been a-been and Crick started to have
the ideas but really the definition by
doing a process known as cell-free
translation where they could very
carefully add components to understand
how the the code the genetic code was
formulated where they put in specific
messenger rna's and amino acids and
transfer RNAs and actually made proteins
from that
so that's what the work that Khurana and
the others did and that was awarded them
a Nobel Prize for that work and then
later on things started to get you know
these are decades of work I want to
point out to you the ribosomes were
discovered that was you know a decade
later that's the sort of details of the
structure but not the structure itself
and it was really exciting in the 2000's
when Ramakrishnan states and yo Nath
solved the structure of the right the
prokaryotic ribosomes so each of these
things has taken a decade to happen but
they are fundamental major important
things that we can act on and move
forward to understand more all right
so let's move to the transfer RNAs and
I've flashed up this slide a couple of
times but I actually now have the movie
of the structure of a transfer RNA so
the transfer RNA is a linear segment of
RNA but it's folded up the way ribose
the way ribonucleic acids are with three
four stretches of double strand coming
together and loops in between them and
the one end this is the three prime end
I always try to draw it on the left
because otherwise things get confusing
it's much easier to sort of see where
everything ends up if you put the long
arm on the three prime side to the left
of your picture and what I think is cool
when you look at the structure of RNA we
think of messenger RNA as being a sort
of rather floppy entity but it actually
really likes to form short segments of
double helix it just doesn't do well
with the really long double-stranded
structure the same way that DNA does but
this folded up structure is very
important and it was on the observation
of these folded structures that the
ribosome hypothesis was formulated but
the two things that you want to remember
about the ribosome are that the three
prime hydroxyl group of the last ribose
within this ribosomal sequence is where
the amino acid that's going to be loaded
into your protein is attached so that's
one point and then
is another landmark on this structure
and that's what's called an one of the
loops has a special name it's called the
anticodon loop it comprises three
nucleotides that are complementary to
the nucleotides in your messenger
sequence so this really is a decoder
because at one end it's carrying an
amino acid but it's carrying the amino
acid that corresponds to the code that's
in messenger via that anticodon loop so
it's a large structure but don't mistake
it for being something that's just sort
of amino acid and anticodon a lot goes
on with the rest of the structure it's a
very important structure in in
mechanisms of protein translation and
synthesis okay so here I've got some
that up with a couple more of the ways
that you would see the transfer RNAs you
might see it in this globular form and I
pointed out the anticodon loop the place
where the amino acid gets linked is also
called the acceptor stem and up here I
show you that linkage and you should yes
[Music]
yeah in a moment not quite yet I will
show you structures of tRNA is bound to
there there synthetases which are the
enzymes that load them so there is
specificity throughout that whole thing
it's not just bystander stuffing it's
it's really involved and it's a great
question and I think I hope you'll get
an answer that's reasonably satisfied
from the structure perspective and so if
you look up here the acceptor stem the
amino acid is joined by an ester bond to
the 3 prime end of the mess of the
transfer RNA but hopefully you can see
in here there's the carboxyl there's the
amine and CHR designates the amino acid
where R would be the sidechain of your
amino acid so that's what that looks
like at that end of the transfer RNA and
coming down to the anticodon loop
you're gonna read the messenger five
prime to three prime that's and the
anticodon loop when you draw this in
this configuration actually shows you
that the anticodon loop is anti parallel
to the codon loop to make that good
hydrogen bonding network so that's why I
like to be consistent in the way I
render this structure so the anticodon
loop of the RNA complements that triplet
codon in the messenger RNA alright
yes well it's between the gene the T
hold on I'm gonna what's between the G
and the over here on the left
oh this wheel this white this this guy
so cool you asked that so this guy is um
what's known as a funny base it's
actually that's the symbol for it that
you picked out and it's a base known as
pseudo uridine and it turns out that
these unusual bases show up in RNA
sequences pseudo uridine has an
interesting structure where the the bond
to the ribose ring is not a carbon
nitrogen bond but rather a carbon-carbon
bond and it's a bit more stable so in
RNA there's a some of these other
unusual bases and pseudo uridine is the
most common of the unusual ones it can
still hydrogen bond but it tends to show
up in these sort of different loops and
tone type places okay thanks for
noticing yeah
the G is which is in parentheses
designates that even those sort of
bulges between the real loops can vary
in length so it could be more than one
so that addresses comes back to that
other question but that stuff in between
has variables it has variable bungee
bulges and variable shapes associated
with the synthetase enzymes that I'll
introduce in a minute that it recognizes
all great questions okay all right cool
okay so we've got all of that so now
let's move ourselves so we've looked at
we know the messenger well we're
starting to understand the tRNAs what we
need to move on to now is sort of the
most important part of the game which is
really taking a look at the genetic code
so this table is but one rendition of
the genetic code sometimes you'll see it
in different shapes and sizes in a
second I'll show you one of the other
renditions but it is the absolute the
sort of rosetta stone for translating
messenger RNA to amino acid sequence
okay using codons so this sort of
getting allele of translation
translation okay
so there are a few features of this
genetic code number one you won't have
to remember it it would be foolish for
us to think you could but there are
characteristics about the genetic code
that are very important but first of all
let me sort of calibrate you this would
be the first of the three letters in the
codon and by the way the genetic code
gives you the identities of what are
known as the codons which are that which
is how we designate the triplet of
nucleotides
so you'll hear a lot about codons and
allergy codons of course so the way you
read this table is you read the first
letter so all of these begin with you
all of these begin with C and so on then
you read the second letter and there's
those designations so if I'm going here
here it's going to be starting you you
and then within each block there are the
four alternatives for the other four
bases there's another and then the third
one
basically just designates those so you
can read for each amino acid what
three-letter code on would correspond to
it some people quite like oops got rid
of it too fast
some people quite like this other
rendition where the first of the three
letters is in the center so it's either
GU a or C then the second one comes out
it's in the brown circle and then the
third one is the third letter in the
anti in the codon and then that tells
you what amino acid that corresponds to
will generally tend to just stick with
this one this one table and and stick
with it so you might as well get used to
that particular table now there's a
couple of characteristics in the table
the first thing to notice is that within
that table there is a codon to start and
it's Aug and the one thing that's sort
of sent to drive you crazy is that Aug
codon equal start but it also equals
methionine and in bacteria it equals a
modified version of methionine so if the
ribosome is reading the messenger RNA it
will look for the first one of these and
start reading but once you find another
one of these further into the sequence
it will put in the firing Metheny is
fairly rare there may only be one or two
more in the protein and I hate the logic
of that
but nevertheless it is the case in some
organisms you start with different amino
acids but the most common start is the
codon for methionine as the start so
what that means is that every protein
you translate has a methionine at one of
the terminus would it be at yeah okay so
that's the details with Matheny and the
start codon then there are several stop
codons and I've shown you the three of
them there the stop codons tend to be
used variously some are more predominant
in some organisms than other and some of
them respond differently when the
process of stopping occurs which we'll
talk about in a second but the next
important thing to notice about the
genetic code is that it's what's called
degenerate now when you call something
degenerate it seems like a sort of a
really nasty thing to call them and it
doesn't mean it's so bad it's just a
degenerate it just means it is specific
but it's not what I mean I've got the
right wording here because I always get
this sort of degenerate me oh it's it's
not ambiguous its degenerate that's the
best thing but it's not ambiguous what
this means is there are four several
amino acids more than one codon that's
specified and let's take a look at some
of the examples of that degeneracy it's
most excrete extreme with residues such
as leucine where there are six codons
that specify leucine alanine has four
different codons they all specify
alanine lysine has two codons and it's
generally appreciated that the residues
that have more codons tend to be the
more common in your messenger
in your final protein sequence because
you'll find in your protein a lot of
loose scenes so we need a few more
codons to stack the deck in favor of
putting in more lue scenes but so it's
ambiguous it's some degenerate but what
I mean by it's not ambiguous you know
what it's going to code for the other
place where degenerate codons become
becoming important is that there is
species specificity write that in here
and explain what I mean and what that
means is that some organisms might
prefer two or three of the degenerate
codons and the others may prefer a
couple of the others and what that means
to us in the laboratory is it's really
annoying if we want to express a protein
in a really convenient bacterial system
that we've taken from a mammalian system
our codon mix may not be the same and so
there are companies now that actually
will fix the codons in a gene for you to
make them compatible with a different
organism for expression so it has huge
practical implications to be quite
honest and it can be very annoying in
the laboratory okay and then so codon
usage varies amongst organisms alright
so now let's one last thing so we've
talked about the genetic code it's the
code that's going to be with embedded
within the messenger RNA then the last
thing I want to do is basically explain
to you one more time when you're looking
to read what your amino acids that get
put in maybe you're going to look at the
codon and it will tell you exactly the
amino acid some a long time ago I used
to be confused cuz I thought I should be
looking at the anticodon and I was
trying to translate everything and it
was a real mess but it's the genetic
code in that box that I just showed you
is written down for maximum clarity and
ease of use so whenever you see a
particular three-letter code
on the messenger you will then be able
to know what amino acid it would code so
this is kind of interesting it just
reinforces to you that the codon and the
anticodon are anti-parallel and so what
I want to do is basically in this
diagram you would be reading from the
five prime to the three prime end as the
transfer RNAs attached to the messenger
RNA and that would give you a codon here
that would be a you see if you'd written
this the wrong way round it would look
like CUA so you really want to be
reading five prime to three prime in the
codon and then you can go to your
favorite genetic code map and say this
thing is read five prime to three prime
and the amino acid that gets put in is
Lucy's isoleucine okay so you'll need to
do that be able to do that quite readily
alright next part portion those monster
the loading the amino acid okay so there
as I said this is a many building block
of many parts things so we've got the
transfer RNAs we know where we load them
onto the transfer are the amino acids we
know where we load the amino acids onto
the transfer RNA but we do not know how
that is done so I want to show you
briefly how that occurs so let me just
start by drawing transfer RNAs the way I
usually draw them in a very sort of
cartoon form and to attach an amino acid
to the three prime end of the transfer
RNA you have an amino acid residue we're
just gonna go on here
carboxylic acid I mean actually I'm
gonna draw them in their appropriate
charge states and what I need to be able
to do is faithfully fix this amino acid
to the three prime Oh H of the transfer
RNA and what we do is we need adenosine
triphosphate to activate this pajama
stree
and then the OAH and the three prime end
reacts with the amino acid so I'm just
gonna draw that I'm leaving out steps
because otherwise it's too many and
you'll be cross with me so you attach
through an ester to the amino acid from
the three prime end of these transfer
RNA that's what's done the ATP makes
this chemistry feasible but there's one
more player here and that's the enzyme
that brings them all together which is
known as an amino acyl tRNA synthetase
meaning it's an enzyme that makes an
amino acyl tRNA and it's simply chases
it so that's how its name gets gets
subtracted so with reference to an
earlier question what I'm showing you
here are different synthetases for
different amino acids that show you that
there's a recognition not just for the
amino acid that's being loaded but
rather for the entire transfer RNA so
some of these look quite different
the isoleucine one interacts in one way
the valine one is a little different and
the glutamine one is different again so
they they're e
in the way they interact with the
transfer RNAs so the transfer RNAs are
specific for the amino acid that is
loaded onto them but also for the
synthetase that does the loading that's
how you get the specificity does that
address your question from earlier hello
okay that makes sense right so they fall
into a lot of different families but
they're they're quite varied when you
look at specific interactions between
the synthetase and the amino acid and on
those synthetases there will also be
specificity for the amino acid side
chain
the amino acid that gets loaded let's
look at the ribosome components because
they're the last big monsters ribosomes
have a small and a large
that's the large and a small subunit
they are made up as I mentioned over
here of RNA and protein so small and
large subunits and I've shown them
they're in two different colors the
prokaryotic ribosomes are pretty
different from the eukaryotic ones
there's a higher proportion of RNA in
the prokaryotic ones the new eukaryotic
ones which is kind of interesting and
these complexes are so big and they're
made up of so many protein and RNA
strands that we don't so much measure
them by the number of those components
but rather by what's known as their
sedimentation coefficient which gives us
a sense of the weight of the of the
module of the complex so the small
subunit oh he's back the small sub yet
the subunit would have a 30s
sedimentation coefficient the S stands
for steady burg units it's how fast it
sediments in an ultracentrifuge and the
large subunit would have a 50s
sedimentation coefficient and those
correspond to a certain number of
Dalton's if you see that s gnam that s
term after a number that's what it's
talking about it's talking about the
sedimentation coefficient which gives us
a sense of the size of the complex and
when you bring start to bring all the
pieces together now what we can see on
this slide is the messenger the transfer
RNAs and there and the ribosome all to
scale in such a way that it can really
explain it so what I show you here is
the small and large subunit in orange so
well that's kind of a burnt orange is a
sneaky little bit of the mess
Jinja in yellow are the transfer RNAs
and there's one more unit on here that I
won't describe too much it's a protein
factor that helps all the processes
occur
generally it's thoughts to help the
loaded tRNA come to the ribosome get it
in place and then go away so it's some
of these extra helper proteins that are
involved okay
so let's build a protein because I know
it's the moment we've all been waiting
for and we're gonna walk through how
those pieces come together it's a very
clunky animation but I'm very proud of
myself because I did it myself
so I'm just gonna show you how these
things happen as you assemble a chunk of
polypeptide chain from a messenger and
I'm so the here's the messenger it's
being read five prime to three prime
what happens first of all is that the
small subunit kind of floats her along
looking for the place that would be the
ribosome binding site that I mentioned
here and then sliding its way to
position the start codon in the right
place to start the synthesis once that
happens the methionine that's on its
tRNA the start one gets into place and
at the same time the large subunit
completing the ribosome complex comes
together so you now have large and small
ribosomal complexes stuck on to that
messenger ready to carry on and in each
case your translocating through the
messenger RNA and in each step you're
bringing in a tRNA that's loaded with an
amino acid where these the anticodon of
the amino acid and I've got those little
letters shown on the bottom here is
complementary to the codon that's within
the messenger RNA so we can start
building this protein Aug is the start
codon methylenes the first amino acid
and it's always at the end terminus then
there's another amino acid comes in the
codon was uuu and that corresponds to
phenylalanine and then the next thing
that happens is there's a movement such
that a new bond gets a new amide bond is
formed between the methionine and the
phenylalanine
and and that new bond is an amide bond
it's not any of the others so you're
literally intercepting this complex on
the transfer RNA with the amine of a new
amino acid that's how that comes
together I'm not gonna worry you too
much with the chemical details but a lot
of them have been illuminated by having
the structure of the ribosome and it
shows you in fact that not it's not
proteins that are catalyzing that
reaction its nucleic acids so now I'm
just gonna move you on through the
synthesis in each case building that
polypeptide chain and then moving
translocating this guy leaves the
ribosome moves along this was a good
Saturday afternoons work we've got to
use up all those trna s it doesn't get
interesting till you get to the end so
what we were using up but now we come
and hit a stop codon we have you AG so
what happens here the whole process
slows down because you can either load
what's known as a suppressor tRNA that's
the one that the magenta one that went
up there or a protein release factor can
come in and bind but in either case
there's no new amino acid to come in and
translation finishes and releases the
protein the in in its complete form now
the reason I want to differentiate
between the release factor and the me an
RNA that has the complimentary stop
codon is because the RNAs that are known
as the suppressor RNAs have now been
completely hijacked to make an enhanced
genetic code where we can load lots of
different amino acids using the
suppressor RNAs and if anyone would like
to chat to me about this and I'd love to
because I think it's a fascinating field
but it's a bit beyond the scope of okay
so this entire process took the
following we've got small and large
subunits all the elongation factors and
initiation really
and then in each case the energy is
actually not provided by ATP is provided
by GTP but where ATP is important is
unloading the amino acids onto the
transfer RNAs this occurs at about a
rate of 20 amino acids per second
meaning you're reading about 60 base
bases per per second which is pretty
consistent with the rate of
transcription not the rate of
replication that's far faster okay
sometimes when you're making a lot of a
protein you will see that ribosomes line
up on the met on the transcript on the
messenger RNA and you'll have many
proteins being made at once and at
different stages in the game and this is
a lovely electron micrograph that
actually shows this process in action
and when you have a lot of ribosomes on
one messenger we call them polysomes
they have that name okay good all right
so what I want to do now so does
everyone feel good about how you
translate a messenger into a protein and
the various moving parts you would
always know the amino acid structures
have the genetic code just be familiar
with reading it or making sure you could
pick out which amino acid might be
incorporated in response to which
particular codon so when proteins are
made on the ribosome they have a bit of
a choice they can get made and fold
beautifully into active proteins those
proteins could be modified they could go
to different places in the cell
occasionally proteins miss fold may be
the rate of synthesis is too fast or the
environment isn't right so there will
need to be mechanisms whereby proteins
get degraded if they're not folded
properly but that's the story for
another day it's not always perfect but
what is known now is that as proteins
are emerging from the ribosome they
starting to fold almost immediately from
that end terminus and to ultimately
attain their compact shape the last
thing I want to talk to you about today
is what happens what are the types of
errors we get in translation now
translation
transcription and regulation has some
editing mechanisms to fix errors but
occasionally there are errors in the DNA
that put different amino acids and the
editing at that stage by the way to fix
errors is editing when you've loaded the
wrong amino acid onto a tRNA but what
happens when the DNA message the DNA
starting point is wrong which means the
messenger is wrong which then means we
get a different translated protein so
I'm just gonna give you a couple of
terms here where do we have here and on
all these slides I'm going to show you
the double-stranded DNA I'm gonna show
you the messenger that gets made and the
protein that comes for it and they're
all lined up so you can follow them
really nicely always writing five prime
to three prime except when we have
double stranded because we have to put
the bottom strand in a different order
first of all this entire chunk would be
called the reading frame it's the
portion of DNA that's going to be read
and track and transcribed into the
messenger RNA and when you look at the
two strands you're going to have to
figure out which one is the template
strand and you would figure that out by
knowing that you read three prime to
five prime but you Tran that you
transcribe five prime to three prime
right so you could recognize which of
the two strands you're going to make the
messenger out of once you get the
messenger you come straight to the
genetic code because you can use the
genetic code to translate each of these
does that make sense so this would be a
situation where you have a wild type
enzyme everything is transcribed and
translated properly occasionally though
there are errors that will introduce
defects into the ultimate protein the
first type of error is a nonsense
mutation which might be leaving out a
base pair inserting one substituting one
and this would ultimately cause an error
in the DNA that then causes an error in
the messenger
so let's say we delete by mistake that's
all we're missing the CG base-pair then
the messenger RNA is now different a lot
of the the the base pairs the bases
slide up to fill the gap so we have
what's known as a frameshift mutation
we've shifted things and what we've done
by doing that is introduce wrong codons
so the first codon was read properly the
next one was read properly even though
there was a mistake but then all of a
sudden we get in this mess where one of
the later codons carries a mistake and
becomes a stop codon okay does everybody
see that
so that would be called a frameshift
mutation that introduces a nonsense
mutation and puts a stop codon into your
messenger RNA okay the next types of
mistakes are ones that are what are
called silent mutations it doesn't
matter for example if you made a an
error in the DNA which ended up with an
error in the messenger RNA if you still
code the same amino acid right I go to
the genetic code I'm like oh my goodness
I've got a mutation oh it's fine CCC
codes for prolene
but CCA also codes for prolene so that's
called a silent mutation okay there the
last the last ones are the ones where we
starts to encounter errors in DNA that
results in errors in proteins that may
cause genetically inherited diseases so
let's take a look at that here
it's a missense mutation where we've got
an error in the DNA which has resulted
in an error in the messenger RNA so
instead of valine instead of leucine
we've put in valine that's not so bad
because it's quite what we would call
conservative they're sort of similar
amino acids they have similar
personalities so this is a missense
mutation but it doesn't cause any
dramatic changes probably in the D
and then the last one I want to show you
is a missense mutation that is non
conservative and causes a serious defect
and this takes you back to the beginning
of the class where we put a mistake in
the sequence where we've changed a
glycine to an arginine that's a big
change and I just want to remind you of
the situation in hemoglobin where we had
a missense mutation and we incorporated
a valine instead of a glutamic acid just
through one change in the DNA which made
one change in the messenger which put a
drastic change in the protein that
caused sickle-cell anemia so missense
mutations are where you put in the wrong
amino acids and those are the ones where
you end up in a lot of cases with
inherited diseases nonsense mutations
are not so bad because you probably just
truncate the protein you don't nonsense
mutations aren't so bad because you end
up with a truncated protein which would
be degraded the missense mutations are
the more serious ones because you end up
with a full-length protein that might
have a mistake in it and then that would
affect the function am I being clear
enough to everyone yep good okay I am
going to tell you that I'm handing over
the baton to my colleague Professor
Martin he'll take over on Monday Mouse's
pretty happy is it pretty excited about
genetics and these will be the lectures
that will occur in what you haven't seen
him here he's keen on genetics yeah okay
and that's it don't forget my office
hours on Monday if you need them I think
this field is fascinating once you get
used to the mechanics of it it's really
cool to think of how you go from DNA to
RNA to folded proteins
you